Hi, I'm Barak Michener,
a software engineer
on Google's Knowledge Team.
One of my favorite
additions to Google search
has been the integration
of Knowledge Graph.
We've been working to
add great features, based
on facts and relationships,
to more directly answer
your questions every day.
From charting and comparing
public data about countries,
to relating facts and
entities that allow our users
to more easily explore
what they're interested in.
All possible because
these facts are
related inside Google's
Knowledge Graph,
based on publicly accessible
data from Freebase, Wikipedia,
and the web.
But why shouldn't
you, as a developer,
be able to build your own
smaller Knowledge Graph?
Today, I'm excited to show
you around my open source
project, Cayley, an
open-source graph database.
Written in Go and inspired
by the graph database
behind freebase.com, it
stores structured data
and retrieves
deeper connections,
much like Knowledge Graph
does for Google, itself.
So, here's what I'll cover.
First, how Cayley fits
into a development stack.
Then, I'll demo Cayley
and step through writing
a few simple queries.
Next, if you're coming
to this video from Part 1
of this series, we'll then
use Cayley to load and query
the music data that
Jarek generated.
And finally, we get
to have a little fun
and show off visualizations
that come built in.
So, where does a graph database
fit within your data stack?
A graph isn't meant
to be a replacement
for traditional data stores.
SQL is still great
for tabular data,
and Key Value stores are
great for scale and speed.
But graph stores are meant
to provide developers
with another tool, to
query graph-shaped data.
What form does graph-shaped
data take, and why is it useful?
Graph data comes in
the form of triples.
These are the edges
of our graph, where
some entity relates
to another entity
through some type
of relationship.
For instance, Arthur
Cayley, the mathematician
for whom the project is named,
was born in the city of London.
A triple is simply these
three strings in our graph.
Further, the relationships
you use, or as it's called,
your schema, depends on the
specifics of your data set.
These are sort of the
phrases you might use,
converted into a
machine readable form.
There are many kinds.
I use a lot of Freebase schema,
but Jarek based his music store
on schema from schema.org.
By thinking in terms
of entities, the nodes,
and relationships, the edges,
we can define a complete schema,
a way for graph databases
to represent connections
that humans understand
intuitively.
But why use another
type of data store?
Graphs afford you
a few key things.
One, the ability to simply
represent more complex data
structures, such as
hierarchies and lattices.
It's also great
for social graphs.
Two, the ability to
more flexibly change
your relationships.
Where SQL has traditional
schema-first decisions
up front, and key value stores
are fast and schema free,
a graph straddles the
line by allowing schema
to be more easily changed.
What one might
call "schema-last".
Three, graphs have
the ability to have
self-defining relationships
that can form a greater
ontology toward greater
abstraction and composability.
Which is really just
a fancy way of talking
about combining relationships
to form new relationships.
Like inferring that my father's
father is my grandfather.
And finally, the ability to use
a broader mathematical theory.
Graph theory provides many
algorithms and metrics,
like distance topologies,
cliques, and neighborhoods,
all fairly intuitively derived.
So that's a bit about where and
why graph data can be useful.
Next, let's dive right in
and take a look at Cayley
and run a few queries
against the music graph.
Here's the Query
Editor for Cayley.
The editor comes with the server
and uses the same HTTP API
that your applications
might use.
It's a way of
exploring your data
and testing your
queries on the fly.
In this instance,
we've loaded a data
set on music, sourced
from the Freebase data
dumps provided by Google.
Because Freebase is
open to the community,
its data-- about 2
billion triples in total--
is licensed in the
Creative Commons.
For this data set, I literally
ran grep across the data dumps
and pulled out anything
related to music
and all of the
name relationships.
Which happens to be 134
million triples, altogether.
Back to the Query Editor.
First, you already know
the query language.
It's just JavaScript, the
lingua franca of the web,
executed by the
graph server, itself.
There's a special variable
called Graph, or just g,
with some special methods.
Emit just adds the value that's
passed to the results set.
To access the data in the graph,
we start by defining a path.
Graph dot vertex,
or equivalently,
g.v as is very common,
defines where we start.
So, let's find the name
of our artist, Dual Core.
I add "all" to
actually run the query
and emit all the
nodes that it finds.
And sure enough, that
name is in our graph.
This however, is just the
name, a literal string.
There are many Dual Cores in
Freebase, and in the world.
The processor type
has the same name,
as does, to some engineers,
a type of electrical wiring.
So we need to disambiguate.
If we follow all
links that point
into this string over the
name relationship in Freebase,
we should see all the
things named Dual Core.
And indeed, we see
there are a couple.
Well, we know that the
Dual Core we're looking for
is a musical artist.
So quickly, let's take
a look at a selection
of artists from the graph.
Starting from the entire
graph, by passing no arguments
to Vertex, find all things that
have a type of music artist.
But let's only get 20 of these.
Well, that query seems to work.
We get a set of IDs
from musical artists.
You may have already
noticed the way
a query is generally structured.
Start somewhere,
follow some path,
and then tell the
database to run the query.
That can be all, for
everything, get limit,
for only a handful, or
a couple other options,
covered in the documentation.
So, we know how to
get artists, and we
know how to get things
named Dual Core.
So let's combine
these two paths to try
to find the one Dual
Core we're talking about.
We add all to make sure
we're getting all of them.
And in fact, we find
we get exactly one.
Here's the identifier
for the band, Dual Core.
It may look odd, but it's
all from machines, right down
to the namespace prefix.
Machine identifiers are
the key to graph databases.
Think of them as
primary keys, a way
of representing a single
concept in unique way.
Like a barcode does for
products in the store.
Well, let's find out
where they're from.
I've refactored the
query slightly--
it's just JavaScript-- to
make a function, getArtist.
From there, let's follow the
relationship between a band
and its home city,
music artist origin.
This gets us to the
machine identifier
for the city they're from.
But there are two of them.
If we follow the name
relationship again,
we can find out exactly where
they're from, just by the name.
And it turns out they're from
Cincinnati in the United States
and greater
Manchester in the UK.
Since they collaborate
online, that make sense.
If you are worried about the
efficiency of JavaScript,
a cool feature of Cayley is that
when you call a running method,
like all or get limit,
the query at that point
is compiled into a go
structure and run natively.
So what more can we do,
now that we have the band?
Since graph data
is flexible, we can
ask for any property
we have for artists.
If we change the last
query just slightly
and ask for genre instead,
we get the genres, nerdcore
and hip hop, that they're
associated with in Freebase.
Now, if we can do that
for Freebase data,
let's talk about how we can
combine that with the data
that Jarek generated and
crawled from his music site.
The next step is easy.
We just take the data that
Jarek provided and load it.
Cayley provides a
generic writer interface,
but again, it could
as easily be done
from an external
process over HTTP.
We get the message that
we've loaded 113 triples.
In the context of
a music site, that
might be writing multiple facts
when the artist page is edited,
for example.
We have two graphs, and
loading both is easy.
But how do we know that
the band on Jarek's site
is the same as a
band in Freebase?
It's similar to the name
problem earlier, but in reverse.
We're trying to determine
if one band in one data set
is the same band in another.
This is called reconciliation,
and it's an art
as much as it is a
computer science problem.
It happens even in conversation.
I'll mention Sean, and
you'll ask, "Which Sean?"
And I'll reconcile, "Oh,
Jarek's friend who deejays."
To help do the same
conversational trick
for machines, there's
a special link
called sameAs,
which will tell us
that a machine
identifier in one graph
is the exact same
concept in another.
And fortunately,
Jarek has already
added these to the
link data on his site,
so it's just another triple.
Let's use that.
Here's the URI that Jarek's site
uses, straight from the web.
It doesn't have a
Freebase name, either.
I would try that, but
again, it has information
that isn't in
Freebase schema yet.
However, we know it
has a sameAs link,
so we can follow
that link first,
which takes us to the
Freebase identifier.
Exactly the one
we already found.
Now that we've managed
Jarek's data into our graph,
it's just the same as before.
We have a Freebase entity.
Let's go ahead and find
the genres and hometown
for the band.
We copy and paste our thing.
We change the strings in music
artist origin, and we run it.
We get exactly the same result.
We could obviously
do the reverse.
We could take the genre
and find the entities
on Jarek's site that
have that genre.
Or any combination
of fun connections.
That should give
you a sense of what
traversing a graph
database feels like.
Hopefully, it wasn't
too unfamiliar.
There's a lot more that this
talk is too short to cover,
but it's all on
the project site.
So, now that we've
done the hard work,
next comes my favorite part.
We get to play with
the data and look
at the graph in
interesting ways.
Here's the query from earlier,
Dual Core genres and location.
With a few extra
tricks for readability,
we can ask about artists that
are similar to Dual Core.
That is, have the same
genre and the same location.
If that seems a
little confusing,
that's what query shape
helps you look at,
the overall structure
of your traversals.
Until now, we've
had straight lines.
Dual Core through the name,
through the genre, to the name,
again.
But here, we see something
that branches off.
The top node shows
a relationship
to the band on one side,
through their genre,
and to the band on the other,
through their city of origin.
In this way, queries
are composable,
making it easy to build
complicated relationships out
of simpler parts.
But what about the shape
of the graph, itself?
Can we generate insight
into the music influence
of an entire city?
So, this query
may look daunting,
but it uses exactly the same
schema we've used today.
Find 1,000 artists,
make sure they're
from a place named Brooklyn,
and get their genres.
With the extra source
and target tags in place,
we can switch to the Visualize
function, which is a simple web
app using sigma.js
on the client side.
And when it runs, it
gives us a picture
of the music graphs in Brooklyn.
You might notice a significant
East Coast hip hop hub,
with smaller hubs for rock
and indie rock in the center.
All of the bands seem
fairly well connected,
and they cross
genres quite often.
It's different across
the country, however.
So, let's take a moment
and re-run the query
and look into
Oakland, California.
As it runs, we start to see
there's a great hip hop scene,
but other bands don't
crossover so much.
It's a little more stratified,
it's a completely different
shape, and it's cool
and informative.
That's just a sampling,
but hopefully it
sparked your imagination
on how graphs and graph
data are useful for developers
and can create fascinating apps
for your users, much as Google
does using the Knowledge Graph.
Thank you so much for watching.
Check out the
Cayley project page,
or play with a smaller
live version on App Engine.
Or join Jarek for the
next video in this series.
Have a great day.